historically communities addressed
shortages by augmenting supplies usually
by building large infrastructure
projects such as dams pipelines and
aqueducts and more recently desalination
plants but this focus on source
augmentation has depleted source waters
around the world and undermined global
freshwater ecosystems let me give you a
couple of examples in a typical year
many of the most important rivers in the
world such as the Nile in Egypt the
Yellow River in China and the Colorado
River in the u.s. no longer reach their
deltas in California transfer water to
Los Angeles has desiccated Owens Lake
which now generates roughly six percent
of the asthma and lung cancer inducing
airborne dust in the u.s. in this paper
we're describing an alternative vision
in which the focus shifts from supply
augmentation to improving what we call
water productivity which basically means
getting more out of less water
one of the most obvious examples is loss
of water from water distribution
networks in developing countries for
example approximately fifty percent of
the water that goes into the pipeline
systems from the water treatment plants
is lost either through leakage in the
pipelines or poor accounting imagine
trying to run a business where you lost
fifty percent of your product I mean it
wouldn't be very viable even in well-run
utilities for example in the United
States or in Europe the loss rates are
on the order of ten percent so there's
there's definitely improvement that we
can make in that regard another example
of how we we waste water is is run off
rainfall runs off of our roofs in our
streets and directly into local streams
and the pollutant loading and flow
velocities that are associated with that
runoff are really a deadly one-two punch
to our freshwater ecosystems
in countries you know the number one
concern really has to do with basic
human needs safe drinking water and
sanitation those are the priorities in
developed countries typically we have
access to safe drinking water and we
have adequate sanitation and the problem
is more typically a biodiversity issue
in other words the ecosystem is
suffering because of lack of freshwater
and both of those challenges can be
addressed by improving water
productivity although the details of how
that's done are going to be very
community specific
the first is substitution on the second
one would be regeneration and the third
is reduction substitution involves using
lower quality water in place of higher
quality water where appropriate treated
wastewater might not be suitable for
drinking but it can be perfectly
suitable for landscape irrigation using
treated waste water fluoridation saves
drinking water ms improves drinking
water productivity another example is or
a second approach that's discussed in
the paper is what we call regeneration
which involves treating lower quality
water so that it is for all practical
purposes just as good as high quality
water an example is potable reuse in
which wastewater is treated using
conventional and advanced techniques and
then added back to the water supply in
Windhoek Namibia for example highly
treated wastewater has been added to the
potable water distribution system more
or less continuously since the late
1960s with no obvious adverse health
effects among the population of several
hundred thousand people the third
approach that we talked about in the
paper is called reduction which involves
basically using less water to accomplish
the same task a great example is dual
flush toilets by installing dual flush
toilets which flush different volumes of
water for urine and feces a city the
size of a million people can reduce
municipal water use by upwards of thirty
percent and substantially reduce
electricity costs
comes how do we how do we move from a
situation of near crisis to a more
sustainable situation and one of the
ways that we can begin to address that
is through changing the relationship
with water which involves rethinking not
not trying to get more water which has
kind of been the historical focus but
but really instead we thinking about how
we use the water and how we can use the
water more productively
you